now you don't talk to your daughter now
then still yeah very painful no but does
she know you exist yes how this girls 27
year old girl out there this knows that
you exist absolutely knows your name
absolutely right so and and I had
contact with her til they yanked out of
the country into the talent and every
time I remember I got a Taco Bell
commercial now I went home and she kept
telling me she's too busy to see what
the [ __ ] is she so busy how old is she
even that she was eight seven the
torture started when I was about what
she was about to she told me she was
moving into her mother's house she ended
up moving in with a guy in my neck of
the woods that's [ __ ] cause for
learning weird when you smile slit your
throat and you smile you have to be
honest I know you're being honest right
now but with her eyes and stuff yeah
yeah it's really good so I put up with
it and I tolerated it and I had the two
felonies so I had to behave myself
because the third one they'll say you're
uh and the boyfriend called me a [ __ ]
one day and I [ __ ] him the [ __ ]
face I said he's going down and guess
what you can't use this racial slur and
this city limits a boulder so he threw
it out of court but after that day I saw
her crying in the car and I'm like she
doesn't need this what I bring to the
table what what I was bringing to the
table at that time it was just I was
making everybody's life me and my wife
were just not gonna get along yeah I
came to I was getting the five hours a
week and every other Sunday that's no
[ __ ] even came to me and said I want you
to change her name because people don't
like Spanish people in this neck of the
woods
it was [ __ ] brutal yeah brutal I
dealt with it but today how I pacify
myself is saying that I I gave a life to
get a life even saying I lost a daughter
to become a comedian but hold on that
she's still alive she's still alive and
that he will not talk to me we don't
know yet though
no I've reached that when I
listen I just wanted I know but let me
just be the voice of reason here okay
you just laugh here's ya cuz I was at
you're about to die I love you though
but um here's the book I'm being real
right now and um you know I'm a liar I'm
a deceiver and I I do shadowplay
sometimes but every once tomorrow
there's truisms when I say things
there's truisms and I'm very real and
you're gonna have a real moment right
now okay honest to god out of all the
comics I've met especially in our class
of guys cuz you're in the same classes I
know I never look you up if people think
that I'm in my twenties still but uh
we're in the same class okay you you're
you you're probably one the best Souls
I've met I mean you and I I've always
just you're an honest guy your your hard
worker and you're a nice guy and it's a
shame that there's your daughter's out
there and she doesn't get to know the
great Joey Diaz I think you're a great
guy and I think it's a loss for her you
know I think I would really wish that
she reached out to you and and develop
the relationship because you're a great
guy also I know this for a fact - is is
that because I've asked around his Joey
Diaz a good father to his five-year-old
daughter yeah you guys go to the park I
talked to her the other day when I
called you remember you can't go talk to
uh say hi to um your Uncle Bobby and she
can't hi she said hi Uncle Bobby right
this guy's legit dude I guess anybody
really hurts my feelings that she that
happened I got a second chance okay do
you know what that's like in life yeah
I've had third chances yeah yeah I mean
to have a second chance I got to have a
kid at 50 that's incredible so what was
controlling the card Buddha Jesus on a
child whether the [ __ ] is controlling
the cards the big picture yeah
replace that gap in my life yeah for
right now I'm cool when I go to Denver
before
I do not get in the car and go to
Boulder because I know me you know you
still haven't asked me why I didn't go
to the memorial Mitzi shore why do those
I know me because I know me well we'll
wait I know I don't know but God we need
I need to ask a couple of more questions
dad okay you were not at the memorial at
MIT's Shores oh you were in town
yes yeah why didn't you go because I
knew him it's he wanted bits he wanted
me to go down and smack two
[ __ ] that's sure okay I get
we're saying bets he liked controversy
yeah yeah it's he loved all that [ __ ]
yeah and guess what what I'm bad if you
remember Malan what team is when I went
off on Jeff oh yeah oh yeah mother's
funeral there was a fistfight the first
night and when I was a kid a kid died in
the eighth grade and there was a huge
brawl and don't come to my funeral so I
don't do well if you're the words I'm
the type of guy that go hey may I talk
to you for a second didn't you [ __ ]
torture Bobby Lee when he's alive
get the [ __ ] out of here before I stab
you in the neck I play security guard at
funerals that's how I was right that's
right yes I was right the way you're
raising
[Music]